大家好,感谢英语开源社区的邀请,我是玛依宝,
车嫌联合定价项目组的技术开发,陈超。
今天给大家分享一下,英语在新联员车嫌联合定价中的实践。
主要呢,有以下四款内容。
首先是那个当下新联员车嫌所面临的困境。
第二部分是玛依宝车嫌,如何使用英语打破上述困境。
第三部分是我们构建的这个车嫌绿洲平台,
然后给大家讲解一下联合定价的这样的一个案例实践。
第四部分就是联合定价在新联员车嫌当中的应用,
以及未来的展望。
首先我们来看一下新联员车嫌当前面临的一个怎样的困境。
一方面新联员车的销量以及渗透率保持着高速的增长,
2024年的整体渗透率已经达到了40%以上。
另一方面新联员车的赔付率却居高不下,
整体都高于燃油车10%以上。
整个行业在新联员车的业务上其实都是亏损的。
新联员车高赔付的原因,总结下来主要有以下三点。
第一,新联车车主普遍年轻化,
新联车用户中年轻的新手车主较多,
而偏好激进驾驶的人群也集中在年轻的群体当中。
有大事统计,年轻人的出现概率普遍高于中老年人。
第二部分,新联车的加速性能更强,
新联车引擎的百公里加速能轻松的赶上燃油车的超跑,
也因此,极加速和极减速的频率显著的也高于燃油车,
它的事故发生率相较于燃油车来说就更高。
第三点,新联车的维修成本更高,
新联车它的车型通常采用异体化的压柱,
同时搭载着电池和大量的电子传感器等元器件。
往往它只能换,不能修。
新联车的整个的零针比整体要比燃油车要更高,
也因此它的维修成本也更高。
更进一步的,新联车的高培夫的局面
也带来了车主和保私之间的矛盾的漩涡。
一方面,站在保险公司的角度,
因为事故率高,修车成本高,形成了这个城堡的亏损,
只能提高这个头宝的门槛,提高报价。
这比如前几年这个特斯拉刹车疫情期间,
就有部分保险公司他们拒保特斯拉。
另一方面,站在用户的角度,
会感受到新联车,头宝男,头宝贵。
而按照新联车这样的增长的销售增长趋势,
预计在2028年左右,新联车的保有量将超过燃油车,
而新联车,它的高培夫的困境,
也就成为了我们必须要面对并且要解决的问题。
而解决问题的关键,在于让保私能够空好培夫,
怎么控培富呢?
我们从培富率的计算公事来分析。
呃,我们可以看到,
培富率它是等于培富成本,
除以保费收入的,
在不额外对和培维修环节做控制的情况下,
核保核定价,
是影响培富率的最重要的因素。
呃,行业通常基于用户的风险,
给出对应的这个车嫌定价。
风险低,保私会适当的让利。
风险高,保私就会适当的提高他们的保费。
而问题的核心在于,
保险公司往往很难精准的去识别这个用户的风险,
低估风险会导致吸收太多的高风险车主,
也会导致这个定价偏低,
最终带来这个较高的培富率。
而高估风险,
又可能会让低风险用户被核保拦截,
导致定价偏贵,
让保私的这个市场竞争力不足。
精准的,只有精准的这个预测风险,
实现这个公平的保费定价,
才是解决新的原车,
车嫌行业困境的这个重要的手段。
接下来,我们讲讲,
蚂蚁宝车嫌是如何使用英语,
打破上述困境的。
呃,在此之前呢,
容我先介绍一下,
什么是蚂蚁宝平台。
可能,很多人还不太了解,
蚂蚁宝是蚂蚁旗下的一家保险代理平台,
其中,联合了上百家保私,
提供了从资询销售,
再到理赔的一战士的保险服务。
而蚂蚁宝车嫌,
聚集了十多家主流的车嫌公司,
帮助大家在一个平台上,
去做到各家保私报价的比价,
真正降低,呃,那个,
用户选择车嫌产品的成本,
并且能够给到用户好价格。
那么,什么是好价格?
我们怎么给到用户好价格?
从前面,我们也知道,
只有精准定价,
才能解决信念车这个高赔付的困境。
为此,我们也需要了解一下,
车嫌金算是如何给一个用户,
车嫌用户进行定价的。
传统的这个车嫌金算过程,
大致可以分为如下的这四个步骤。
一,数据预处理过程,
用大量的数据进行筛选,
还有清洗,选择出合适的数据样本。
二,特征加工,
通过因子分析和处理,
寻找并加工出对车嫌出现概率,
赔付金额影响最大的特征。
三,模型训练,
车嫌的赔付一般都符合推理的分布。
同时,车嫌业务上为了保证一定的可解释性,
普遍采用GM广义线性回归模型。
最后,产出一张静态的金算费率表。
到最后一步,上线预测,
GM费率表用于产出纯纤保费,
也就是预测赔付金额,
基于定价策略产出对应的折扣,
最终给出车嫌的报价。
从数据的处理,
加工再到费率表的产出,
也就是车嫌金算的整个过程。
金算的视角集中在如何更精准的
练化识别用胡风险。
这里我们会注意到,
车嫌建模的两个关键词,
数据和金算。
传统的车嫌建模在上述两点上,
其实都面临着不小的挑战。
传统的车嫌金算建模在数据上存在着孤岛问题,
而在建模上存在着效率问题。
涉嫌于数据的能力,
传统车嫌金算对风险的刻画,
主要通过从车的静态数据,
比如品牌型号,车零,车价等,
几乎没有车主相关的数据,
而根据统计策算,不同类型的特征
对风险的刻画能力的它的影响是非常大的。
刻画能力从低到高来看有这样的一个顺序,
首先,车辆信息,
也就是刚才说的那个从车的静态数据,
它对风险的刻画能力偏弱,
这个其实也很好理解,
同样是那个宝马三系的车主,
有的车主是一年三次出现,
有的车主他三年一次出现都没有,
重点情况是非常普遍的,
车辆信息对风险的刻画是非常有限的,
其次是用户的画像,
车辆的出现概率,
主要还是看开车人的影响,
容不容易出事故,
谁在开,比开什么车,
起到的影响更大。
第三是过往出现的情况,
受驾驶,习惯等因素的影响,
过往的出现能一定程度上的
趋于是未来的出现。
第四类数据也就是用车行为数据,
比如用车的频率,用车的偏好,
及加速,及减速,超速等情况,
也是最能刻画用户风险的特征数据,
对于后三类数据,
除了过往出现数据,
用户的画像和用户行为类的数据,
保私往往是很难接触到的,
而拥有这些数据的主体,
往往受限于数据安全,用户隐私,
很难共享给保私直接使用,
于是就造成了这个数据孤导的问题。
另外,在传统的精算过程中,
精算建模的过程大量济于
专家经验的手工活,
每一个风险因子都需要投入大量的时间
进行分析、处理,
使用的工具也都是简单的
XL、SARS等数据统计类的软件,
建模过程整体要以月为周期,
此外,车险也是区域经营的显种,
一地一侧,
再加上一险一侧的情况是很普遍的诉求,
每个保私有将近40个分支机构,
再加上车险多个显种都需要单独的精算,
意味着平均每个季度需要进行
上百次的精算模型的迭代,
而如何高效地保证规模化与精细化
是我们必须要解决的问题。
于是,麻衣宝车险推出了联合定价项目
解决上述的这些难题。
麻衣联合头部多家保险公司
在过去一年内实践并广泛应用的联合定价技术。
一方面,我们基于隐私计算技术,
让数据可用不可见,
解决了数据孤导的问题。
另一方面,
我们基于体内批避级的金融和车生态数据
构建了行业最广的人车价实行为关系图。
基于大规模图学习和图计算技术,
识别出真实的人车关系和高威的价实行为序列。
从而能够推测车辆实际价实的价实风险。
例如,同一个家庭车辆,风险相对去同,
而经常进行夜间高速武价实,
其停击杀的这些车主,
他们的风险就相对较高。
仅检验,
蚂蚁的风险特征,
能够为宝斯识别并量化风险的能力,
带来近60%的效果的提升。
此外,
我们使用AltML的思路,
从精算到定价策略,
进行了全链路的自动化升级。
风险可实现自动化的迭代。
建模周期,
从一个月,
直接减少到三天,
实现了精细化的动态定价的覆盖。
相应的,
我们将联合定价系统架构,
也分成了三层。
在最底层,
我们引入了隐私计算,
开源项目,
引语,
实现了真正的数据的跨域共享,
让数据在各个主体之间可用而不可见。
在中间层,
在精算的能力上,
通过组建库模板化的方式,
让传统的手工精算过程,
系统化,自动化,
并让精算经验低成本的
跨机构,跨显种的附用。
并在个别的精算组建上,
创新提效,
为车显精算,
带来了极大的效率和效果的提升。
在最上层,
也就是联合定价运营层,
我们提供了运营的监控和策略的产出能力,
实现了高效的响应和运筹的平衡。
针对数据孤岛的问题,
我们引入了英语,
实现了端道端的联合建模和预测。
传统的精算建模模式中,
一般采用残差的方案,
也就是保险公司原风险模型不便,
单独训练残差模型,
这里的残差是指风险预测的误差,
残差模型通过风险特征,
来预测保私原模型的误差,
因为风险特征与误差等身并无相关,
这种方式很难带来很好的效果。
而基于隐私计算技术,
可以实现蚂蚁数据与保私数据,
它的一个端道端的建模,
能够充分的发挥多方数据特征融合的价值。
而针对精算效率问题,
我们通过组建化的方式,
快速沉淀了20多类精算组建,
比如单因子调优,
集差评估等组建,
并构造标准化流程模板,
通过配置化实现精算经验的快速复用,
然后针对因子调优问题,
我们通过分组自动化搜索合并的分享策略,
保证因子入模式的单调性,
还结合模型融合的思想,
将多个因子风险组合投票,
提高因子对高低风险用户识别的准确率。
上述流程的自动化,
解决了精算式的双手,
极大的提高了精算废率表的产出效率。
然后我们再来看一下,
联合定价是如何对风险进行管控的,
联合定价的风险分为两个方面,
一是精算模型正确性的验证。
定价过程往往会横跨多个主体,
而每个主体之间,
会有大量的定价因子参与定价,
并有海量的测试用力。
常规的测试手段,
是根本无法覆盖上述所有的情况的。
第二个就是,
业务效果验证的制后型,
一般在建模阶段只会进行模型,
AUC,MAE等性能的评估,
发布阶段进行正确性的验证,
在最后到AB实验阶段,
才会通过线上指标判断它的业务效果。
那么整个过程的沉默成本和试措成本,
让业务无法快速地响应与跌淡。
为此,
我们玛尔堡车线,
就是构建了一套风险防控体系。
在试前,
定义集差作为直北星,
通过模型打分的邪律,
刻画模型性能和业务影响之间的关系,
让业务影响能在精算报告中提前预知。
在试中,
我们建设了仿真的体系,
在模型上线前,
通过流量的回放,
保证测试用力的覆盖,
并通过仿真报告,
观察新老模型的风险分布,
保费的分布,
还有折扣的分布,
通过对比分析,
能够及时发现模型可能的问题。
通过对报案里培得实施的监控,
进行满气培护率的预测,
及时发现定价策略的偏移,
并通过纠偏策略予以及时的纠正。
通过上述的风险防控体系,
我们能将实际培护率
控制在一个合理的水平线上。
在看第三部分的内容,
我们将联合定价的技术,
进行的产品化的封装,
构建了一个车线的绿洲平台。
那么,
什么是绿洲平台?
我们又做了怎样的产品化的工作呢?
我们先来看一下联合定价最核心的流程。
不同于传统的报价,
马尔宝仅仅向保私询价的做法,
联合定价会在马尔宝仅与保私
双方部署隐私计算节点,
节点部署完之后,
双方的数据会在训练节点做隐私求交。
在隐私计算平台去做模型的建模,
产出的车线费力表
会在预测节点上做部署,
最终运行阶段由业务系统来发起调用。
通过隐私计算的密泰模型联合运算,
最终给用户呈现它的车线报价。
在联合报价中影响车线报价的风险因子,
包含有马尔的从人特征分,
隐私计算让双方的数据可用而不可见,
而马尔的从人特征分能更好的区分用户的风险,
这便是联合定价它最核心的流程,
但仅仅只做到这样还是远远不够的。
马尔宝车线基于AutoML技术构建了行业,
首个车线定价自动化平台,
让定价的全流程全部实现了线上化,
包括数据的采集,
建模,评估,反馈,监测,以及废率表的调整,
且整个的流程形成了动态的避还。
原本需要计算师大量线下进行的工作,
均实现了机器的替代,
例如特征的筛选与分组,
模型的评估,废率表的调优等等。
通过定价自动化平台,
保私能够更快速地制定和调整废率,
从而能够更高下的去适应和面对行业风险的波动,
从而提升保私风险经营的能力。
再简单地展示一下绿洲平台,
平台能够实现全自动化的建模,
其次也支持人工手动的建模,
像这里展示的DEG图,
就可以由计算师手动选择需要的用到的组件,
比如说数据的求交,分析,加工,
模型的训练,还有评估等等。
在英语通用化组件的基础上,
车线也搭建了一些定制化的组件,
比如说车线计算专用的GM训练组件,
以及一些可用于计算报告的模型评估组件。
此外,在模型训练完以后,
模型的上线部署与效果的评测也实现了自动化,
从而真正实现了,
从模型的训练,
再到服务的部署,
再到运萎的监控,
最后到反馈调优的全自动化的
车线计算模型的迭代流程。
然后在这里给大家录了一个演示的视频,
请大家也可以看一下。
传统的车线定价的过程复杂,
包括特征拆选,人工调餐,
特征分析,集杀计算等,
步骤繁多,EIXL,SARS等传统建模工具,
平均一丝定价建模研发的周期在一个月左右,
效率很低,
蚂蚁自研自动化定价建模平台,
通过制定标准建模流程,
实现了数据处理,
特征分析,模型训练,
评估和优化等全流程的自动化,
定价建模时间从原有的一个月将低到三天,
在特征工程中,
应用风险巨类等Otto ML技术自动完成特征筛选,
分统,交叉,将精算专家经验和Otto ML融入到系统之中,
兼顾了高级差和可解释性,
并应用到太平洋产险等保私中,
提升级差效果11%进入到精算建模阶段,
系统根据模型评估结果,
自动调整特征结构,进行模型调优,
然后生成可实化的特征分析报告与模型评估报告,
简化重方在联合建模过程中的沟通协作,
提升了模型的审核与上线效率,模型最终确认后,
平台通过部署、验证、发布、切流等一战士服务,
提升保私部署效率,将低线上风险,
基于自动化建模平台,
蚂蚁实现了八家保私,
进一百个定价模型的快速介入和优化迭代,
游效保障了模型迭代的速度和效果。
看完了我们绿洲平台的一个演示视频,
传统的车鞋定价的过程复材。
最后再简单的分享一下我们现在的应用的成果。
在新的原车的联合定价当中,
大宗小型的保私目前都有介入,
用户平均降价了三百块钱,
真正实现了新原车车鞋价格的普惠。
举一个保私的真实的案例,
某保私在上线的联合定价之后,
其端道端转化率提升了80%,
UV效果提升了70%以上,
相当于这家保私的业务结果,
通过接入的联合定价,
达到了一年甚至两年的这个提效。
绿洲联合定价应用了之后,
大约有38%的低风险车主,
平均降价了10%,
15%的车主从无法报价,
到了获得了一个合理的报价。
接入新的原车联合定价的这些保私中,
大部分保私开始扭亏为营,
其综合成本率也均开始低于1%。
最后一个部分就是未来展望,
过去联合定价完成了
从0到1这个过程,
并且实现了规模化的覆盖,
其创新式的风险定价方式
为行业带来了巨大的价值,
但整个新的原车产业庞大,
数据主体众多,
未来主机场修理场,保险中介,
保险公司等形成的产业互联,
是一个较大的趋势。
隐私计算也为这个趋势带来了可能,
这部分我们要继续围绕数据与AI,
持续打磨风险量化的能力,
为新的原车行业带来金融普会。
此外,新的原车险的经营
与远远也不只定价这一个环节,
从营销、核保、定价、理赔各个环节
都对综合成本率有着至关重要的作用,
未来隐私计算技术将不仅服务于
车线封控定价业务,
也将拓展到其他需要多方保私合作的项目,
其构建的保险机构数据网络,
也将为整个车线行业提供更加广泛的发展空间。
以上是我全部的这个报告内容,
谢谢大家聆听,感谢。